- [Gary] Thanks for coming out.
I'd like for you to go around the room
and introduce yourself and
tell me where you're from
and a little bit about yourself.
Go ahead.
- I'm Ade Nadir, I'm from Dallas.
I'm working on a modern business school.
- Modern business school.
Very cool.
- There's a lot of things you talk about.
- Yeah, I believe in it.
- I wanted to make a
difference and change it.
Master class has normal
people teaching the class
and focus on entrepreneurship and mindset.
That's the first thing that we work on.
That's the thing I wanna work and teach.
But I will...
It's like amazing people that--
- What were you doing before?
- We a tobacco business,
manufacturing tobacco hookah pipes
and hookah tobacco that
we sell internationally.
That's a family business.
We've done that from '03,
and I left the day-to-day
in 2015 and then started
working on consulting.
I was like--
- Family as in like sibling or--
- My brother started in his bedroom
and then my whole family
got involved in '05.
So I left the flight test engineering job
at BAT helicopter to
then work there with him.
That was nuts, totally
did all of that stuff.
Successful land on the
link 500 list and so forth.
Then when I left in 2015
'cause I wanted to do something different.
I went into consulting and then I realized
this is a broad impact and I was focusing.
When I was working with people,
I realized mindset was something
that was really beating up people.
So I started working on that
and finally figured out that
I wanted to do business school.
- That's cool.
- So in the middle--
- In Dallas?
- Massive failure.
It's a line, so a live event.
I did a mobile tech start up.
Totally crashed that.
In that concept of connectivity though
was like well lemme still do that.
Lemme just be a real life version of that.
So that app was called Refer Me
and it was about connecting people.
- That's really cool.
- So then I just bring those
people and put them on camera.
I'm the back burn, I'm
the platform for it.
- I understand, very cool.
- Thanks.
- Nice, I'm Todd Bookspan.
- Hey, Todd.
- Father of three.
Just had my 28th anniversary
here on Friday with my wife.
- Congrats.
Where do you live?
- Phoenix, Arizona.
- You guys kick, so it was good timing.
You did it in New York?
- Flew in a day early 'cause they canceled
our flight on Wednesday.
So caught the last flight out of Phoenix
on Tuesday night; so we got lucky there.
Wear a couple of hats
through start coaching
and mortgage industry and
other industries as well
a couple of years back.
Developed a sales performance product
for loan officers and real estate agents.
That's kind of my passion
now 'cause I feel that
I can impact more through that product
than I can one on one.
That's kinda what I'm here
to figure out how to continue
to grow that scale as we move forward.
- That's cool.
- [Mikyle] So Gary, Mikyle
Jessen; I'm from Chicago.
I run a company called
National Corporate Credit.
We raise money for
start-ups, small businesses.
I started with a buddy of mine in 2008
right out of high school,
so I didn't go to college.
Been growing ever since.
- Good timing.
- Good timing, yeah, good timing.
So we've been building it ever since.
Kind of been in the trenches
doing deals through a lot of JBs.
Don't really have much of an influence
or standpoint just yet.
But that's what I'm here to learn.
- Okay.
- It's good to be here.
- I'm glad you're here.
- Thanks.
- [Brian] Brian McKan.
Met you a couple of months ago.
- Yup.
- [Brian] You did a shout out to my sister
who was terminally ill.
My sister, who doesn't
complain, as my Aunt would say,
won't say shit with a mouthful.
Her response to your video,
and she's not effusive man,
she doesn't put it out there.
She looked up and said
I'm gonna save it forever.
Alright and I'm gonna say a lot more
right this second 'cause of that.
- Yeah, we'll come back around.
- [Brian] Yeah.
- Appreciate it my man.
Means a lot to me.
- Chris Clothier from Memphis, Tennessee.
Married with five kids.
- Whoa.
You guys aren't foolin' around.
What are the ages?
- 16, 12,
eight, six and three.
- 16?
- Yeah.
- You had a baby when you were three?
(group laughing)
You look good, man, for a 16 year old.
- He was born when I was 30.
- Wow, you look great.
Cool, one more time, 16?
- 16, 12, eight, six.
Oh wow, nine, six and three.
- Amazing.
- She's (mumbles) for that.
That's amazing and good for you.
Go ahead.
- We own a family business.
- Okay.
- With my father and brother.
- Father and brother.
- (mumbles) State Investment Firm.
- Okay.
- My wife and I have a
charitable foundation we run.
One is called Kids Kicking Cancer
and then the other one is Charity Water.
Big supporters of Charity Water.
Yeah having fun, man.
I was tellin' somebody yesterday.
I've only had one job for someone else.
Ever since I was 17, I've
worked in the family business
or started my own businesses.
- Very cool.
- So this is excited to be here.
- Awesome.
- Hi Gary, my name's Christy Ray.
I'm from Sunny Buffalo, New York.
I have a newborn so I---
- First one?
- Yeah--
- Congrats.
- She'll be 22 weeks tomorrow,
so this was the thing for me to be here
overnight flying.
So this was like--
- I get it.
- 'Cause I'm so smitten with the girl.
I own a water filtration
business with my dad.
It's funny 'cause we're heating
air conditioner contractors
and we wanted to sell a
water filtration product
to our customers and we
couldn't find anything we liked.
so we actually---
- Made it?
- Developed our own.
- Scratch your niche?
- Yeah, we then started
selling the product
to other heat and air
conditioner contractors
and plumbing contractors to
let them sell to their---
- And away it went.
- And it went.
In the meantime, I was able
to get some celebrity testimonials.
I think you'll find it interesting.
All celebrities are customers of ours.
I didn't pay one cent
for those testimonials.
- Interesting.
- Nice.
- I thought you'd appreciate that.
- That's very cool.
Whenever you build the
best product, you win.
- Yeah, well, my business
model's kinda flawed
because now I'm reliant upon a plumber
whose in the house to sell the product
while he's in the customer's house.
It's a really tough business model.
- I'm aware.
- So what I'm looking to do
is get some ideas about how I can---
- Go direct to consumer.
- Yeah.
- I totally get it.
- Thank you.
- Hi Gary, I'm Neva Rami.
I'm originally from India.
I moved to the US in 2015 for college.
I think it was the summer of last summer
where I saw your video on Snapchat about
how you scared about what people
are going to do after graduating.
- Yes.
- I think you blew my mind.
I was like I need to know who this guy is
and what he is about.
Since then I've been following you
on every platform possible.
I want (mumbles) to hear this.
- I'm aware.
- Competition.
- Yes I'm aware.
(group laughing)
It's cool.
- I'm not established in any industry.
- Of course.
- I'm 22.
- Yes.
- Jumping from (mumbles) to (mumbles).
- Tasting.
- Yeah, tasting everything.
That was initially what
I get on any (mumbles),
I was like whoa, I'm gonna
make a million dollars.
- Of course.
- The moment I get my first order,
I'm like, whoa, I'm gonna
make a million dollars.
This is it.
- I think that's a good trait
as long as it's grounded
with you're not gonna
make a million dollars.
You have to balance
optimism with practicality.
I think everything, literally, every idea
that runs through my
head, including the two
that have happened while I've
been listening to you guys,
I always think is gonna be everything.
I think that's good.
I think to your point and it
was funny to your reaction
after listening to your story.
I've been talking a lot
in my content right now
to 20 to 25 year olds around tasting.
Everybody's biggest
problem is I don't know
what my passion is or what I'm good at.
I'm like, cool.
So taste.
If you don't know what your
favorite food is, taste shit.
Eat salmon, eat broccoli,
eat sea urchin, eat burgers.
We don't have that system in place.
I think for the rest of us here,
that are a little further along after 22,
the thing you realize is
20 to 30 is exactly when
you should do high-risk.
Because as we start building families
and other things in life happen,
we have to react to that.
That puts us on defense.
So I've been really
thinking a lot about...
It's funny, I'm a kid who started working
literally the day I left college.
When I drove from Boston to New York,
that night when I got to the store around
three or four PM, 'cause
I left in the morning.
I actually worked for three hours at my...
'Cause I always worked when I was home.
It wasn't like symbolic;
it was just normal.
I got there at four and
you don't go home at four.
I just got to the liquor store
at four with the traffic.
I just literally literally parked the car.
Gave a huge hug to one of
my best college friends
who was taking a bus to the city
and he was on his way to the life.
I literally just helped customers
for the next three hours
until dad was ready to go
home and we just went home.
From that day to now, I've always worked.
Normally, 99 out of 100 times,
everything you hear from me
is advice that I've done on myself.
So that's why I'm so confident in it.
Ironically, one of my favorite
pieces of advice right now
is something I did polar opposite of,
which was because I found the meal
that I became addicted to very early.
But I've come to realize
that that wasn't the case
and isn't the case for most.
I just think it's practical
to hustle at this age.
Try different things.
Some of us stumble upon it
in an alteration of our own business.
Sometimes we just bounce away from it.
Everybody's got their own stories of it.
A young dude like this,
his business is very conditioned
to the market behaviors.
So I'm sure he recognizes it's a good era
but it can get bad and
so what am I gonna do
when it gets bad?
But it's great that you're tasting.
You should think everything's
gonna be a million dollars.
What you wanna do though is not
get caught in a couple ways.
Number one, I think a lot of
people get caught on good.
So where you could get caught
is you can actually make
100,000 in that first year.
But actually this is on
it's way to a million,
but the upside was 200,000 always.
That's a very sneaky one,
very hard to dissect.
Alteration of great, like
picking good over great.
But you should feel
comfortable in your tasting.
- When did you know it
was the right time to...
Okay, there's another world for me.
I've gotta move onto the next thing.
I don't have to cry about--
- Nobody's gonna...
One thing I tell people is
you're never gonna know the alternative.
You're never gonna know that
if you quit the day before,
the next day was gonna be
the beginning of the future.
You'll never know.
That's how I live;
that's how I strategize.
The answer is it's scary.
I'm convinced that there
are millions, not millions.
There's 10,000 people
running around right now
that were literally one
day away from it clicking
and they went and got another job
or went back to business school.
That's real life and nobody
wants to be that person.
Somebody watches these videos
like fuck, am I that person?
That would be devastating.
(group laughing)
That's devastating.
To me, it's a function of something else.
It's a function of humility
and what your aspirations are.
Let me explain.
The reason I was destined to win
is the process was the win.
I'd won before I started.
Being an entrepreneur was it.
So to me, I never had to worry about that
because I never allowed
the way I lived my life,
and I mean expenses.
Look, if you're willing to
live in a studio apartment
with three roommates in
a ghetto neighborhood,
you forever can be an entrepreneur.
People only talk about the moneymaking.
I'm gonna make a million.
I'm only saying that I can live on 10,000.
That keeps you in the game forever.
I think a lot of this has
to do with what one does.
You have the luxury of time right now.
Hopefully you stay healthy forever.
You've got 80 years in
front of you minimally
with modern medicine.
That's a lot of fuckin' time.
I think the only thing that can hurt you
is what hurts everybody at
22: your parents' pressure,
your own pressure on
yourself because you see
your friends startin'
to accomplish things.
What's that?
- That's happening right now.
- Good.
So to me, I had psyche that was crazy.
I loved that at 26,
my good student friends
were starting to make money
'cause they went to a good school.
They went to Goldman Sachs
and they were makin' money.
They're buying a BMW and a watch.
I fuckin' loved it 'cause it
motivated me in a great way
because I knew who I was
and the snarky comments...
Now I'm Gary V to everybody.
Just listen very carefully.
I'm 26 and I work for
my dad's liquor store.
- Yeah.
- You gotta really understand where I was.
I'm 26 and I'm working
for my dad's liquor store.
That's my brand amongst my
circle four years outta college.
Because I wasn't promoting
that the business
was growing very rapidly.
Attaching your own happiness or sadness
to somebody else's actions
is the quickest way to lose.
Your buddy making money
has nothing to do with you.
It just legitimately has
nothing to do with you.
Your buddy making money
and getting pretty girls
because of it just legitimately
has nothing to do with you.
I understand at 22, you
wanna hang out with pretty...
I get it.
I understand what people want in life.
I understand the psyche
of men/women, young/old.
It all makes sense.
It just doesn't have
anything to do with you.
The sooner you can get to that place...
I just shut everything out
because then you can stay patient.
Mindset.
- Yeah.
- But that's where people get caught.
- Expectation.
- You know?
Parents, pressure, or tryna
keep up with the Joneses.
Outside forces.
- Hi.
I'm Brooke Wood.
- Brooke.
- I am 24 years old
and I design websites for estheticians
and beauty industry professionals.
- Very cool.
- So it's a service-based business.
- Do you design on top of platforms?
- I design with Squarespace.
Because they like to
manage their own website.
- Makes sense and it's certainly
an easy one for them to manage.
- Exactly and it keeps--
- It's a great platform.
I'm very friendly with the
founder of Squarespace.
I'm a big fan.
- The only thing, I love their platform.
I'm addicted to it.
- Yes.
- You couldn't take me off of it.
I hate the (mumbles)
program because I, you know.
- They don't need it.
- Exactly.
But I just wanted to come here today
because literally I was
thinkin' on the walk here.
- You live here?
- No. (chuckles)
- Where do you live?
- I love on San Diego.
- In San Diego.
- Yeah.
But it was just like
a year and a half ago,
so summer of 2016, I literally
couldn't afford lunch.
I dropped out of college three times,
which was really hard
'cause both my parents
were college professors
and pushing that hard.
It wasn't for me in a year.
- Sure.
But you were tryin' to make them happy.
- Right.
- I get it.
- Because they're good people.
It's like you don't do--
- I mean I'm the most anti
college person on earth
and I went to college for four years
'cause I love my parents
and that's what they wanted.
You know what's funny?
I wasn't worried about making...
I literally was checking the box.
- Yeah.
- I was checking a box for them.
- Yeah I dropped out of
community college three times.
- Yeah, yeah.
By the way, Mount Ida's
below community college.
You know it's funny.
I'm such an optimist.
I actually haven't thought
about this in such a long time.
I did say this to somebody recently
Maybe you have this (mumbles).
I literally converted it into vacation.
I viewed it as my last vacation.
I knew that I was gonna be a workaholic
'cause I already was.
I literally just transformed my mind.
I didn't go to camp; I didn't
hang out in high school
or junior high 'cause
I worked all the time.
That's what I did.
Anyway nonetheless, you
dropped out three times
and then a year and a half
ago you couldn't afford lunch.
And then?
- And then I started
listening to your content.
Your message of getting your act together,
do the right thing, work hard.
It was just like duh.
So I stared just doing random...
I've always had an eye for
design, so I did random things.
I learned Photoshop literally
through YouTube videos.
- That's exactly right.
- Eight hours a day just like--
- Yup.
- Then I would take on
projects that I knew
I wasn't qualified for, but
I just learned on the go.
- Yes.
- But now it's turned into
a six figure business today,
so I just wanna thank you.
- That's awesome, you
should thank yourself.
There's a lot of people
consuming my content.
You did something with it.
It's cool, I'm so glad you're here.
- I'm Niles from Chicago.
I started in advertising when I was 21.
Basically got fired on
my birthday and my boss--
- At an agency?
- It was radio direct
marketing, direct mail.
We do the creative.
- Yup.
- All that stuff.
Basically my boss called
me, but I (mumbles)
before he called me,
fired me on my birthday.
I'm like look, give me two days.
I got a bunch of leads I'm working.
Lemme come in and show you I can close
those I have that I'm working.
Come in the next day and then
ever since that day, came back,
literally close out those deals.
Stayed in advertising probably
a good part of eight years.
Was top salesman 24 months in a row.
Crushed all their records
and ultimately just started--
- Did you need that
push when you got fired?
- I think I did.
- Yeah.
- I think I probably did.
- Yup.
- Maybe it was something
I was lookin' for.
- You know what's funny.
The reason I asked you
that in a thoughtful way
of what was going through my mind
is I'm fascinated by talent.
I'm fascinated by school.
I'm just fascinated that I
did nothing for 12 years.
Me, it makes no sense.
- (mumbles) it doesn't make sense.
- Kind of like if you're
that good of a salesman
but you weren't performing before,
it's interesting that
that's what was the trigger.
- That was the trigger.
- I think people get
motivated by different things.
I do not get motivated by
negativity at all, firing.
When clients call even when I need it...
For my whole life, even when I was tiny.
Baseball cards, as a kid lemonade.
I go the other way.
Everyone's motivated by different things.
Just understanding that
is fascinating to me.
I think it's predicated on talent.
- Right.
- When you have talent,
you're subconsciously
understanding things.
It doesn't make any sense to me
that what I'm about to tell you is true.
No third grader should be sitting in class
and realizing this makes no sense
and will not impact my life.
You shouldn't have that level of wisdom.
I can't wrap my head around
that that's what I...
I actually did that.
Who knows what words I used.
I assume they were different words.
So the fact that you could
sell that well but weren't
and somebody's saying you're fired,
that was it is cool and interesting.
Anyway nonetheless.
- I don't give a shit, you know.
Too bad.
- Right.
- Show up, you're supposed
to be here at none o'clock.
You're done.
- And you finagled your way by 48 hours?
- He hung up, he was (mumbles).
I called him back and said,
"Look, I get it."
- You're right.
- He's like I don't give a f--
- Yeah.
- It's your birthday.
- He's right.
- Yeah.
I'm like look, I got a ton
of leads in the system.
Gimme two days.
If I can't close anything, I'm gone.
Ultimately I ended up closing all those.
I ended up climbing the
ropes all the way to manager.
- So cool.
- VP then partner.
- So you're there for
eight years and then what?
Decide you're (mumbles) okay?
- They launched a separate
division on (mumbles).
I went there for two years.
It's probably 2007, 2008.
Ultimately it was just
nobody was working out there.
There was no growth.
- By the way, it's so funny.
I have the funniest point of
view on Arizona and San Diego.
- I grew up in Arizona.
(Gary laughing)
- San Diego freaks me out.
I go there--
- For a year.
- It freaks me out.
I go there and all the
entrepreneurs there...
I don't know if anybody's been there.
It's really the nicest place on earth.
It's super nice and it's so chill.
I feel like New York's starting
to get even slow for me.
So do I need to move to China?
I'm looking for the action
and San Diego freaks me the fuck...
I get there and I'm like this.
You know, like ugh.
So many of my entrepreneurial
friends live there now
'cause the lifestyle's so great.
It's funny, it's funny.
Where I was going is
actually a complement.
Anybody who's actually working
hard in that environment
really I give a lot of credit to
because it's just so easy to get...
I get sucked into nice weather.
When I'm in LA for three days on business,
by the third day, I'm like right.
I need to get the fuck outta
here before this tricks me.
- Yeah.
- So basically after that,
there was nothing going on.
- Right, right yeah.
- I was working through
happy hour every day.
It was such a boring town to me.
Everything shut down after 10 o'clock.
- And this is the Delta from Chicago?
- Right.
- Which I think
is tier two by a landslide.
Go ahead.
- And then I end up
just movin' back, right.
So I sold my shares and
said no, this is not for me.
There's no more growth left.
- Yup.
- Moved back and then launched
kind of a similar type of ad
agency for about two years.
It was getting a little bit of traction.
Then one of my old buddies
I used to work with
was in real estate.
He yelled to me and said,
"Hey, I've got a great idea.
"We can launch a brokerage.
"I've got all the way the
leads work and all that."
So I said, "Alright,
let's give it a shot."
So we give it a shot and our leaving,
closing down the ad firm,
going full force into the real estate.
That (mumbles) of not working out.
So ultimately just had
to pick up the pieces.
We grew the brokerage
to about 40, 45 agents.
But our overhead was 20, 25 grand a month.
It was just killin' us.
People were ordering
stupid office supplies.
It was retarded.
It was like what are we doing?
We need to clean house
and basically just find some rock stars,
be a boutique shop.
So we did that over the years.
Ultimately now, we're about 14, 15 agents;
but all super seasoned.
We're kind of dumbing it down
to more of like a true boutique shop
where you wanna work with
a big shop you can, but
(mumbles) give you better service,
a more personal touch
et cetera, et cetera.
Then use all our knowledge
from the advertising world
will apply to real
estate because the system
was really broken I thought.
95% of the agents in my
opinion are incompetent
and just honestly don't
know what they're doing.
So that later brought me
into launching the startup
that I'm working on now,
which is interesting.
I think one year past the worst you gave,
you pulled them out of it.
You said it was dogshit or
something like that, whatever.
It's similar, it's not
transaction management.
But it's more data driven.
So ultimately, it's a platform
where it allows a broker
not to be incompetent,
where it has all of the data
in there preloaded for them.
But it also helps them with training.
- It's a SaaS business?
- It is, yeah.
So that's where I'm at now.
- Really cool.
- So business is still going.
- Great.
- I'm in the third stage of development
with a--
- It's cool.
- Well great, let's just do Q&A.
We're not here to hang out.
Who's got a question?
- [Brian] I wanna tell ya.
Brian again.
- What's up, Brian.
- Yup we figured. (laughs)
- I manage a real estate
office for (mumbles).
Program manager for about 60 agents,
about 40 live ones
in about three hours north of here.
Gino Blefari and Chris Stuart
hooked me up with that
NFL thing we were at.
Because Gino's way up there
on the evolutionary scale,
he told me, "If I leave here
without telling you this,
"find another place."
- I love it.
- He said, "He woulda
had ya at Vayner on board
"a year earlier as our marketing firm."
He said, "I had to put the
executive who's in charge
"of that decision in my NFL."
I said, "What is that?"
He goes, "Not for long section."
He goes, "Let him know it
wasn't a group decision.
"This was a mandate from
me," he said on a Sunday
a couple of weeks ago.
So you got a big fan.
- I know that.
- Yeah.
- I've been in business long enough
to know how this stuff works.
Yet there's sand.
What I do for a living always
is not what people on
defense want to hear.
- Okay.
- The most remarkable part of VaynerMedia
and its success is I haven't
been selling anything
anybody wants yet.
(muffled conversation)
This most remarkable
part of this company...
You probably know this best coming from
a little bit more of that world.
VaynerMedia is selling
to a group of people,
biggest companies in the
world: Budweiser, Chase.
Services and strategies that
nobody in upper management
or senior management or super
senior management believes in.
So the reason I know that's the case
is 'cause I've spent time with Gino
and he's an entrepreneur.
He's like let's talk about the 49ers
and I talked about the Jets.
When we left there, I looked at
one of my employees and said,
"We're gonna get this account."
They're like why do you think?
I'm like 'cause he's gonna force it.
- That's exactly right.
- And I believe that.
- He made the decision.
He said this wasn't and yeah.
- And that's how things happen at Vayner.
I let the team do tons of shit.
I don't even know what's happenin'.
It's a big company.
- Yeah.
- But when I know something's happening,
it's not gonna be a group decision.
If I'm involved, I'm gonna
assess it and decide.
What I mean by that is if
it's something important
that nobody else would support.
- And he sees the light in it?
- 100%.
It's also just he's smart.
I always say...
My life has been super
interesting over the last 10 years
where other people have been
involved outside the customer.
My life is basically about the customer.
This is interesting with you.
This is your business right now.
The thought of being at the
mercy of a fuckin' plumber
is not interesting.
Not because it's a plumber
and I'm shitting on a plumber
or a real estate agent; it's
that you're dealing with
somebody else who has other financial
vested interests and ambitions.
If you've got a passive plumber
who's wrapping it up soon
and is super happy with his or her life,
doesn't care how much
money they're gonna make
on the referral fee.
- Yup.
- 'Cause they wanna
have the extra conversation
once they get home.
- (mumbles) their fire.
- By the way, you'll enjoy this
and this is a little bit of a curve ball.
I don't need everybody to be on fire.
I'm motivational in the fact
that it's a manifestation
of my optimism.
It's why I haven't built the
business you're building.
I just want people to be practical.
I'm super not anything else.
If you pay attention, it's
why I made a reference
to you already about like hey brother,
please make sure you're
paying attention everyday
to the macroeconomic climate
'cause that's your vulnerability.
That's practical.
I'm far more immigrant than
I am motivational speaker.
If you really dissect me,
it's just about staying alive
and paying your bills.
And doing it in a way that
if you're gonna do that,
doin' it in a way where it's fun
to wake up in the morning versus not.
For example, a lot of our businesses,
maybe they're not as scalable.
But who gives a flip?
To me, here's where it
gets to it's basic form.
You know how many people can
build a six figure business?
A lot less than people think.
Actually you just made my day.
Yeah you.
Especially if you're under 25 right now,
this notion that everybody has to...
The fact that almost every
entrepreneur right now under 30
thinks that a million
dollar revenue business
is where it starts.
This thought like I'm
gonna build a trillion...
Why you got caught is you entered the land
of trillion dollar businesses.
You're not building the next Instagram.
People get it; there's like 18 of them.
You know how hard it is
to build a consumer app?
I know you know now.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- You know how expensive, how hard.
People raising 30, 40
million dollars in capital
and failing with ease 'cause it's hard.
I want to start championing...
I think it's remarkable to be
able to do something you like,
have a six figure business because I know
you can have an incredible life on that.
The average income in America is $51,47...
What's the number?
The bottom of the 1%
wealth in our country,
the richest country in
the world, maybe China.
I don't know, but fuck
we're in there, right?
The bottom of it is
400-something thousand a year.
If you make 400,000 a year and up,
you're in the 1%, the 1% of America.
But the talk and the
branding of entrepreneurship
in business is 28 million.
It's so crazy.
So I'm obsessed with practicality.
That's what I like.
I like that a lot.
- Unfortunately, you're
the only one sayin' that.
You see everywhere, whether it's--
- Oh I know.
- No matter what it is,
every ad is about the car,
the jet, the watch.
(muffled crosstalk)
It's romanticized.
- You can make $100,000 in
six weeks, it's ridiculous.
- You did it right?
How do you get the mindset of everyone.
It's out there.
You're puttin' out great
content of what people can do.
- I don't think we do.
If I'm not worried about
it, you surely shouldn't.
Meaning we just do.
Your true stories are what matters.
Once you get to that place
where you're good with yourself
and you're tryin' to give back,
you can only give back in your truth.
Go ahead, brother.
Yeah.
- When I taught fifth grade
30 years ago or 25 years ago,
taught kids, I thought
school blew as a teacher.
- (chuckles) Yeah.
- I was in a small city.
- Taught fifth grade?
- I taught fifth grade and fourth grade.
- You thought it was bad for them
or bad for you or bad overall?
- The whole thing was just complete
utter bullshit.
- Garbage.
It's real bad.
You know what's really sad?
Is that's 25 years ago
with the actualization
of the internet, it is so broken now.
Back to practicality, it
was already somewhat bad.
It now makes absolutely,
positively no sense.
We're making kids...
85% of the kids in this country
are memorizing information.
- But I think there's hope.
- I don't know
what to tell you.
- I'm gonna tell you what I
think the hope is and that is
I selfishly as a 25 or 27 year old kid,
not kid sorry, young person, at the time
of mentally a kid did
some things in my teaching
to entertain me and to make
my job more interesting.
It made me a far better teacher.
- Yeah, they like you too
'cause you were a kid.
I would be a great teacher at 42.
I wanna teach fifth
grade right now so bad,
you don't even wanna know.
- So bad.
- I'm comin' guns a blazing.
- I made a mistake.
Nevermind.
But here's the thing, it was a great job.
One of the best experiences
I ever had that changed everything
and I wish every young person
could have this experience.
It was by mistake.
Chancing cars, the watches and the things
all changed when they had this unit
and it was a bunch of
file folders worth of shit
about the holocaust and
about this and about this.
It was just terrible,
so I said, "Screw this,
"I'm not doin' any of this."
We did our own unit making kids...
We made blond-haired kids sit
in the back for a couple days.
We treated 'em like shit.
Parents got all--
- This is shit you could do 25 years ago.
You can't do that shit now.
- You know what we did though?
Lemme tell ya somethin'.
We ended up bringing....
This is the one thing and I'll stop.
I probably won't but
we brought a survivor from
Auschwitz in and she sat.
The first thing she did is
she had a paper bag with
bologna sandwich in it.
She goes, "I'd carry this everywhere
"because the closest I came to death
"was at 15 years old when
I took a bologna sandwich
"that was moldy outta the
garbage at the guard's hut
"and I was beaten half to death for it.
"So everywhere I go, I
have a bologna sandwich."
- Interesting.
- These little privileged kids
look at her and go (mumbles).
Then she rolls up the sleeve
and showed her tattoo with the numbers.
All of a sudden life
got real and I realize
what she had done was
change 30 lives that day.
- The problem is and you know this.
She changed 30 lives
that day for 24 hours.
The thing I live in is practicality.
You're driving fast, one-handed,
fuckin' bein' ridiculous.
Lights go on, you shit your pants.
You slow down, it drives past you.
You're like fuckin' thank God.
You chill for about 12, 15 minutes,
then definitely by
tomorrow and most likely
by the end of that trip, you're back.
You go to the doctor,
your blood test is weird.
They call you back in, you
fuckin eat healthy that day.
You fuckin' are scared shitless.
You tell people you love them.
You're doin' everything right.
False alarm.
Three days later, you're back.
The thing I think I'm
takin' a lot of pride in
and this is the internet.
This isn't I'm more
special than other people
that had ambition to
communicate before me.
It's the reason I think I was able to
creating more results,
is 'cause I'm consistent.
- You made it very clear
the goal shouldn't be
I wanna make a million
dollars when I'm 25.
- But I made it...
Some people, maybe you heard it
from the first podcast and the first video
or maybe 99.999%, it was the first piece
of content that made you
go down the rabbit hole
that then got you stuck
and then I pounded you
for 187 days in a row.
Then it was like, wait a
minute, that might be right.
'Cause that's what it is.
- That's true.
- That's exactly---
(group laughing)
- That's it (mumbles) right?
- Yeah.
- There's no one piece of content...
Even the song you heard
from the Rolling Stones
or Martin Luther King's...
Yes, in hindsight, but it's just the seed.
Far more extreme versions don't change us
back to health scares.
So that's the beauty of
what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to gather all this attention.
To keep it for a long
enough period of time
that it actually makes an impact.
That's why I think I'm
resonating 'cause...
- Why do you change up your
stories and your content
and your subjects so often?
To keep everyone's attention.
- You know what's funny?
I think that is actually less strategic
and more just who I am,
which is probably why I'm...
That goes down to other
things which is like,
that's probably why I was bad at...
I don't keep myself interested...
I've started realizing about myself
is I'm a big time listener
even though on my shows
I interrupt people.
Like you know you were
making a joke about yourself.
You know you're gonna want to talk.
It's how you do things.
But I'd be surprised if there wasn't
someone listening from it.
I talk so much to create
listening opportunities.
I'm throwing things at you and watching
how you're reacting or what
are you gonna bring up,
which gives me white space to go into,
which manifests in a new piece of content.
Even the one I just posted today,
I kind of gotten to in
the last couple of weeks
this idea, and it's been an idea before.
I've said it before but I'm hot on it,
of like you're gonna find
what you're looking for.
You wanna find negativity,
you're gonna fuckin' find it.
Let's go, let's fuckin' put
on fuckin' CNN and Fox News.
Let's go on Twitter and
we can all fuckin' think
the world's gonna end tomorrow.
Or you could search on Twitter right now,
thank you so much for,
and just see unlimited
stories of kindness.
Go search what's so kind to me.
Go search on Twitter right now,
was, so, kind, to me.
I know you're gonna
see all sorts of things
like it was really nice of
this person, was so kind.
Like helped me today, so
I'm fascinated right now
of you'll find what you're looking for.
You're looking for
optimism, you'll find it.
You're looking for...
That's why, back to mindset, or the seed,
or what I'm tryin' to get through.
I think the thing I'm
trying to do is take on
the responsibility that I have a message.
That I'm a personality and a human
that has always had
the ability to resonate
with youth and with elderly.
I would say I do better
with 70 to 90 and 15 to 25.
Obviously which is interesting
'cause most of this room isn't that,
but that is where I win.
Because if you're super wisdom out,
you can see through everything
and you've got me pegged quick.
Nine year olds understand
me always the quickest,
then 15 years olds get excited
by my communication style.
I don't really have a horse in a race.
I don't care why somebody thinks I'm cool
or worth listening to, I could care less.
I just want them to listen
'cause I know what my intent is.
I know I can win that game
and I know I can keep their attention.
That more out of less strategy
that I'm gonna change it this Thursday.
Babin will tell you,
probably could answer.
It's literally like we're living.
I'll say something, I get
excited at my own shit.
I'm my own number one fan.
It's just true.
I'll say somethin' like, "Oh
shit, that's fuckin' rad,"
then I'll put it in my head.
Again, Babb then Iris and D-Rock see it
because they'll see it.
They now understand how I do it.
I've learned through
their eyes how I do it
which is I'll say something,
I'll like how it feels.
What's that?
- Tuition-free in your bag.
- Yes, exactly stuff like that.
Or like something in here,
I'll like the way it feels
and then he'll see I'll
use it again tonight.
All of a sudden I'm doing it
and then three weeks
later, it's the thing.
It's cool, it's been fun to
learn it through the process.
- Could you talk about voice for a minute?
Get some real estate focus in the room
and how would you do it in bad mortgage?
- I think it's early for voice,
but I think back to practicality.
First thing is everybody should
have an Alexa in their home
and you should force
yourself to do things with it
that don't come natural.
It comes natural is say play Billy Joel.
It comes natural say what's the weather?
I'm tryin' to break Alexa.
I keep askin' it.
- Very easy right now.
- It's very easy right now
'cause it's not that advanced.
But it's helping me to understand,
it's funny to see what I'm
tryin' to ask it things
what's coming out of my mouth.
I'm tryin' to make pretend it works great.
Just like I did with the iPhone,
which eventually led to
a lotta success for me.
I look at Alexa and Google
Home like the iPhone.
It's a new platform that's
gonna get built on top of.
Twitter, Instagram, Spotify, Waze,
these are all apps on the iPhone.
Uber.
Uber's an app on the iPhone and Android.
I don't think what Alexa does
today means anything to me.
I don't have the right answer,
but I couldn't wrap my head
around people not doing things.
You have to understand voice
is gonna work in your car
and your home and it's
gonna be inter-compatible.
This is real life to me.
What are we, 2018?
In 2027, a couple sitting on a nice day
like this on a Saturday morning
sayin' what do you wanna
do, what do you wanna do?
What are we gonna do today?
Do you wanna do anything today?
One of them's going to be like,
wanna go see open houses?
I dunno, we wanna move don't we?
We should go look at some houses.
What happens in real life today now?
They go to their computer
and they go on Google
and they start looking.
That's real life.
To me, Alexa, would you like
to go to some open houses?
Alexa's like, I got you.
You go in your car and
Alexa's like, you ready?
You're like, yeah, and you go there.
That's real life.
That's exactly how it's gonna
work 'cause it's faster.
Why the fuck am I gonna
print something out
for a move I did seven years ago?
Put it on my phone which means
I can't then use my phone.
- Yeah.
- Right?
So it's gonna do everything
that the phone does.
Once you understand that truth,
then you realize what's different on voice
that is on written, on
audio and video, that's all.
But it's gonna do everything.
Serial, right?
That was the podcast that exploded?
That entertained us.
People listened to Serial in podcast forum
the way our great-grandparents
listened to the radio
in their living room
and listened to sitcoms
that later became...
What old is new, what new is old.
Everybody here is going to be entertained.
Do all of you listen to a podcast yet?
- Oh yeah.
- That wasn't real four years ago.
For example, Alexa, Google Home,
in the car in the real estate business,
huge from utility.
Which brokerage or which macro brokerage
is going to build the best app?
How are my leads?
Your leads are this.
What are my openings?
Do any of my clients have
an opening in their calendar
because their calendar is matched to...
They've got Google's infrastructure.
Google has Google Calendar.
They have Google Home.
All you have to do is
(mumbles) or give permission
to your Google Home device to
have access to your calendar.
All I have to do as a contact
of yours is do that as well.
Now Google sits in the middle and I say
I really wanna see Babin.
Tuesday, April 13th would be best.
You both have four hours of opening.
Would you like me to contact both of you?
Yes.
I don't need an assistant.
Technology.
- I have a question.
- Sure.
- Okay, so I am reaching that plateau
where it's just like I
only have so much time
as a service---
- You need to hire somebody?
- Yeah.
- Or you wanna do something else?
Okay.
- Hiring a designer is hard
'cause it's in your mind.
Like designing whatever.
But I'm very well aware that websites...
I'm not going to be doing websites
when I'm 34 years old.
- Right.
- (mumbles) someone who's
been in the tech industry
for a long time and with your experience,
what should I be investing
my time in now to--
- Ahead of it?
The good news is design
never goes away as a macro.
It's design.
It's visual.
We will always look.
(speech muffled by static)
- How I started it is I
started a Facebook group.
That's how I got all my leads.
I never paid for advertising anything
so I would just do little videos,
tips, market tips or whatever.
Then that Facebook group grew to 5,000
but they're 5,000 very active numbers.
- I totally understand.
- I love them.
That's how I've been
getting my business so far,
so I don't know if that helps.
(speech muffled by static)
- Any context you guys
can give me is gonna help.
I think you're asking
two different questions.
One is the output and one is
the lead gen to the output,
which both matter.
So the question becomes which
one are you most focused on?
They both matter, so I get that.
- Right now I'm most focused
on doin' the actual work.
I hardly put out any
content 'cause I'm so busy.
- I get it.
The question is couple things.
One I would scratch your own itch.
The first thing I would start with is
what do you want to design?
If you didn't have money (mumbles) at all,
what would you want to design?
If that is as far-deviating as
clothes instead of websites,
that's something we need to talk about.
If it's always on top of
technology interfaces,
well that's great.
There's a lot to talk about.
There's also different levels of design.
Some are just pure
design, maybe some is you.
I don't know how much you care about
or do the UI or UX.
So if it's more on the arts side,
we need to play that out.
If it was on the UI UX side,
which it's not, which is fine;
but if it was,
I'll tell you, the most
interesting thing in the world
right now to me is the UI UX voice.
We don't know how to talk
to these devices yet.
Why is there hashtags on Twitter?
Because Christmas Cena
posted a tweet one day
and said, "Let's start using hashtags."
Twitter was so small that 4000 of us
that kind of ran shit, were like, okay.
That's literally why it happened.
But why do you swipe up?
Why do we do anything we do?
People made decisions.
They made design decisions.
- Where do you find the
vast UI UX people today?
- What is UI UX?
- User Interface and User Design.
You know, it's just experience.
User interface experience I
think is what it stands for.
I just know it as the
way it's referred to.
The people who really sit
there and try to make things
create the least amount of
friction to create the results.
- Right.
- How do you take friction
out of the system?
You should have seen my library.com 1996.
You'd have been a
mathematician to place an order
'cause we know who to
execute a shopping cart.
Like, toot, toot, everything, right?
So the mouse is here, how do you go?
Your eye goes to the top left.
What colors are...
All the stuff that goes into
a proper design for functionality.
It's pretty aesthetically, it looks right,
it makes you feel warm and
then there's do you convert?
There's a landing page.
Does it convert?
How did he enter the
contest that he went into?
Like, got it.
- Okay.
- So super important.
For me, it came natural
to me 'cause it's how
I thought about my dad's liquor store.
Because I was 14 I would
stand behind the register.
It was not that busy, so every customer
you could have the focus on.
I would just watch how they would...
This is what I've done my whole life.
I watch people.
I would just watch how they would walk.
I would be like they're all
going to the beer section,
that's less profitable.
What if we block them and
make them go this way?
I did that, it worked.
Everybody picked up more
stuff, it was crazy.
Now you feel like you're in control.
It's a fun job.
If you're a UI UX designer,
it feels very powerful.
If you think about it, you're
playing maze with humans.
- The reason I ask that
too, I've been through
about 12 so far and none
of them have worked out.
I'm on the next one now.
- You know what's it's tough right
but it's even more tough with design.
The biggest thing, if
you want to scale it.
So you just wanted to do
exactly what you're doing
and the answer's scale.
It's not being the judge
and the jury for the client.
Your designers have to get through you
before they get to the customer
is your biggest vulnerability.
- [Brooke] Okay, that's exactly
what I'm doing right now
'cause I'm like---
- Can I give you a real insight?
- [Brooke] Yeah.
- It's ego.
I think I'm really good at what I do.
- I get it and guess what, you may be.
I don't think anybody here
gives better marketing advice
when they're with a client.
But that's not what my
clients are paying for.
They're paying for better marketing advice
than the alternative.
What Berkshire was doing with
fuckin' Gary Boner BBDO whatever,
the good news is it's
way better with us now.
If I did it personally, it'd be better.
But that's not what we're selling here.
That's what you need to
wrap your head around.
- [Brooke] Like 80% is good enough.
That's part of your clues.
- Here's the best part.
Some people hate your shit too.
(group giggling)
It's not about 80%, you got it?
- [Brooke] Yeah.
- It's about understanding that it's
a subjective call.
- That's right.
- I'm just on emotional ones.
- [Brooke] A lot of stress.
- It will relieve a lot,
wait 'til you taste it.
Now it went through you head,
your like that makes, oh.
Wait, that's a different
way to look at it.
- [Brooke] Direct
communication with the clients
and nothing's going through yet.
- But you need to do is make sure
that you don't undermine your employee.
So a lot of people listen to me on this
and they're like, that makes
sense and they're pumped.
Then stop doing it differently
but what they're doing
is they're subtly undermining
their own employee
'cause they like the feeling
that their client thinks they're better.
It's ego.
- [Brooke] Oh okay, that makes sense.
- Its ego.
Ego is killing people.
It's funny, I'm such a
front man for my company
and I have my personality;
but again I promise you,
Babin, his biggest insight will be
the humility more than the ego,
or the lack of touching everything.
The economy.
So not only do you have to let it go,
and let somebody do their
thing, you shouldn't even...
The only reason you should
approve is if something's
completely off the reservation.
- [Brooke] Should you
even look at it before---
- Only if it's completely
off the reservation.
I think I watched Babin's
first four, seven, nine,
help me here.
- [Babin] I mean more than that but--
- Because I was watching all
the daily (mumbles) back then.
Took me a little while to
let go of daily (mumbles)
'cause there's so much
sensitive information.
But I have now which is crazy town
because we're filming some shit.
- You didn't have to be (mumbles).
I kinda snuck in to the
franchise owner breakfast.
Completely snuck in to the franchise owner
in San Antonio a month ago
and your team was there.
You had some personalities there.
That was awesome.
But I noticed you were
mentioned in the beginning,
just in the background, building up the...
But it was nothing do with Gary Bate.
- Yeah.
- It did have something to do with---
- The philosophy of this
company is built by me.
It's even funnier than that.
Even look at this.
Even if it's me in the
room, all I'm trying to do
is figure out you.
If you have customers,
it's about the customer.
Sometimes it may seem heavier than others
only if my team feels that
they need to use me as...
In the same as I'm trying
to be a shield for you guys.
My great goal right now is to help
people that are insecure
use me as what to point to,
to be in the argument at home.
To me, I want people to say Gary V said,
not 'cause it feeds my ego,
because it gives them courage
to finally have the conversation.
- [Man] The information thing, alright.
- So my team can use me if they feel
like they need to.
- Tool in a toolbox.
- [Man] And it lets you
grow, lets you keep going.
- 100%, 100%.
Just never would have been anything
that matched my ambition.
If my ambition was far smaller,
yet ridiculously huge,
this would be what I would
be doing for a living.
I'd just hang out with
businesses and make a fortune.
I make a million dollars
a day enjoying the shit.
I make a million dollars a
day being put on a pedestal
and getting my ego stroked all day.
Yet I run a business that
made 1.4 million in profit
last year 'cause I invest
it all back in the business.
That's me eating my own dog food.
That's me at 42 speaking about patience
and building to a long term.
'Cause you just don't go from zero
to buying the Jets on a singular move.
It's not how it works.
- [Man] I wanna try to
go direct to the consumer
and bypass the plumber
(mumbles) contractor.
It really starts off with
who really is our customer?
- Yes.
How much does it cost?
- [Man] A whole house system installed,
a plumber would charge
probably about $5000.
- Well first they're rich.
- [Man] We have a less expensive system.
- How much?
- 2500 bucks.
- Let's start with the rich.
- Okay.
- But that helps.
When you think about who your customer is,
sometimes when you're
in your own business,
it's hard to understand
certain things like this.
That's a fuck load of money to have.
That's a really good starting point.
- [Man] One of the things
we were thinking about
was who's our end customer.
- Rich people.
- [Man] Yeah, and one of the
things we were talking about
is obviously people
who have kids and that.
I've got a 22 week old baby so I'm---
- No, 'cause you have enough money.
I'm tryin' to help you here.
I don't give a fuck
how many kids you have.
2500 bucks is a ton of money
to the average person for a water system.
Because when you don't have...
If you're not making over
$100,000 a year, probably more,
the water out of your
sink is more than fine.
- Yeah.
- Delicious.
- [Man] So would it change--
- (mumbles) change everything.
That's why I'm zoning, notice?
- Okay.
So how then if I'm gonna look at it,
obviously people who
have kids who are rich,
what would be the starting point
where you would be content about,
would I be doing content
about what's going on with me
and my daughter?
- There's a lot of
places to go so let's...
Before I jump to conclusions though I did
and I feel like I'm right
about that one conclusion.
Help me break it down, what is it?
You come into people's homes and what?
- It's a water filtration system.
- The water coming outta your sink is
like what I have 'cause I'm rich.
- Everything in your whole
house is gonna be filtered.
Everything in your whole house.
Cook with (mumbles), shower, everything.
- That's right, that's right.
First let's have the most interesting part
of the conversation.
- Sure.
- Why is that a good idea?
From your selfish point of view.
- In terms of people don't realize
how bad the chlorine is in the water
if you're bathing your
kids or bathing yourself.
Brooke here, she probably
goes to the hair salon
and spend a lot of money
on your hair, don't you?
- I don't, but we can pretend that I do.
- Okay, then we'll pretend that you do.
A lot of our spouses/significant others,
they go to the hair salon,
they spend a lot of money.
- I'm listening.
- They come home
and the first thing they
do is they wash their hair.
They spend all this money
to get their hair colored.
That chlorine's stripping the
hair color out of her hair.
- That's true.
- 'Cause chlorine's actually,
technically it's a poison.
People don't realize it's a poison
and what it does to your skin.
If you've got a baby, we
talk about baby-soft skin.
- The thing I would say
is my biggest thing,
the most important part when you market
is to focus on the black and white truths
and work backwards.
I feel like the most interesting part
of this discussion with you right away
is where does the data break down?
Lemme explain.
The wine business.
I sold wine for years
back in 1992, three, four
when I was a kid, but it was the hayday.
Because 60 Minutes did a
piece on the French Paradox.
The entire thesis was people
in France are living longer
even though they have fatty foods
because there's products in wine
that are so healthy for you
that you will live longer.
Revesterol, I think?
I'm forgetting already.
It's been so long since...
Once I understood the next
part which was that was it.
It was accepted.
60 Minutes, doctors, they accepted
that this chemical Rivestarol?
Fuck, I can't remember.
I can't believe I forgot.
Is better for you, is good for you,
is great for the heart.
A lot of you have grandparents
or older uncles or parents
that started drinking wine in the mid 90s
because it was good for your heart.
This was real life in America.
- A glass a day, I remember.
- Glass a day.
Then six years, seven years later,
which is why I can't even
remember the chemical right now
or the additive or
whatever the fuck it is.
I can't believe, makes me
feel like I'm getting old
'cause I remember everything
and this was the core of my life.
Then it came out that yes that's true,
but you need to drink 64 gallons of wine
to get the benefit they were innuendoing.
- A day?
- Right.
I'm exaggerating but I
think it was legitimately
10 cases of wine.
It was something no human
could ever even do once,
let alone any kind of common sense way.
To me, if I bought 50%
of your business 49,
we started here day one and
we're about on a marketing plan,
I'd probably spend three
to four meaningful weeks
really feeling if it was
something we could market on.
Because my cynicism is you're right,
but not at the dosage that we're being
deployed in our water.
I could be wrong.
I'm telling you at a common sense human
when I hear that as the marketing lead.
I'm like fuck you, you're doing
that for your self-interest.
The reality is if it was so harmful,
we would've been fucked so long ago
'cause every day everybody's pouring.
Now, you may counter
properly with yeah yeah yeah,
but the subtleties matter.
If you have...
What's that skin thing?
- Psoriasis.
- Eczema.
- Eczema, thank you.
If you fuckin' have that, it's a little
but that really impacts you.
For you, Gary, maybe you don't have that.
Yeah you're right, maybe
you don't color your hair.
I think there's a couple things.
Number one, I think the
biggest mistake marketers make
is they lead with something
the whole industry leads with
that actually doesn't
matter to the audience.
Lemme explain another one
just to get this in your head.
When Dollar Shave Club came out, I saw it.
My father-in-law worked at
Gillette as a top executive
that had sold the company
to Procter & Gamble
but the guy was still there.
The CO, Jim Kilts, was still on the board.
I had a good relationship.
I saw a moment where I
could be historically right
with a legendary guy and I
was like I'm gonna go for it.
I called and I'm like,
"Hey I just saw a startup.
"It's called Dollar Shave Club.
"They just had a viral video,
I think this is something."
He proceeds to tell me and
laugh me out of the room
on the phone by saying,
"Gary, we spend more money
"in R&D than they will raise
in Capital in their history."
He goes, "Look, our shave is
a 100th of a 16 inch better
"for the man than theirs could ever be."
I go, "That's why you're gonna lose
"'cause there's not a single
fucking guy in America
"or the world that gives a shit
"their shave is 100th
of a 16th inch cleaner
"than it was the last time."
I was right.
People cared that it was $1.00
a hell of a lot more than they did
about the 100th of a 16th inch.
A couple things, number one.
Fear as a lead is always capped.
- We discovered that.
- Good!
(everyone laughing)
- If you flip over to the
front of the brochure,
it's really all benefit-based.
- Love it.
Great, so I'm glad you're past that.
There's a lot.
This is a super-interesting business.
First of all, I think I would argue
that everything we just talked about
is actually ironically secondary
and there's just a lotta people
that are willing to buy it
if you made the friction
of them buying it easier.
Just back to your first point,
which is you just marketing...
Look when you have this,
the fact that you can target
fans of the Kardashians on Facebook,
have $100,000 income
and live in your town,
you've already got four
customers from Facebook tomorrow.
These claims are statements.
They're just public domain, right?
- [Man] Yeah, they gave 'em.
They were customers on it.
They said go ahead, use.
- That's awesome.
- [Man] They've got our system (mumbles).
- You're off to the races.
Any of them actually friendly
with you, like beyond?
- [Man] I don't talk to any of 'em,
but remarkably all of them had been--
- Did they say yes through their plumber
or you guys reached out to them?
- [Man] Interesting thing was
I found a company that
was doing gift bags.
- Celebrities that happened.
- The Grammys.
- That happened to offer your system?
- Yeah, I put my system in
there and that's how I got 'em.
- You put these in their homes for free?
- I gave 'em for free.
- Smart.
I believe in that shit.
I believe in free a lot,
which the design community hates me for.
- [Brooke] Hey that's how I started out.
- No shit, you and everybody else.
Then when people make
it, they tell everybody
not to give 'em for free
'cause they don't like the competition.
(everyone laughing)
Fuckin' assholes.
Pisses me off.
They act like they're
noble to all the kids.
Hey designers, don't give away.
It's your net worth.
I'm like fuck you, asshole.
I know for fact you worked
for free in the beginning
and now that you fuckin'
charge $1,000 an hour,
you don't want the supply
and demand to change.
Piece of shit.
It pisses me off.
Look, do you have a way to
capture the business now
on your website, direct or not yet?
- [Man] Well we've got a transition.
We've got our existing site now
that our plumbers use and whatnot,
then we've got a transition
site that we wanna launch
to go direct to the consumer.
We've done some ad words testing.
The good news is we're
getting people to the site.
The bad news is they're not buying.
- Do you have a video?
- [Man] Yeah, I actually
got two different videos.
It's funny we've got
one is a benefit-based,
one is more of a health scare type base.
We've got both angles covered.
- Understood.
There's a couple different things
that are running through my mind.
I think about B2B in this sense a lot.
One of the things I think
is super interesting
is getting to the developer level
and having it default into the homes.
Then I'm thinkin' about what could you
possibly bring benefit to those homes.
One of the things, there's
a big arbitrage right now
of people that know how to market.
One of the reasons I want
you market progressively
is just to capture the
eye of the developers
in your region or in the country.
I could see something like
the Toll Brothers company
default putting this into their homes
of a certain income level in
return for you teachin' them
how you marketed B2B
transactions on social media.
I know that's super--
- [Man] It's funny because
me getting plumbers to carry this,
I had a business model to do that.
But it was getting them
to actually do something
was the difficult part.
Getting the business owner
of the plumbing company,
I'm able to get him to say
I wanna sell your product.
But then to get his
actual plumbers to do it
is a whole other--
- Yeah,
but I'd want my builders to do it.
- See where I'm goin'?
- Yeah.
- 1.2 million dollar houses to include it.
- Alright, lemme keep thinking.
- [Man] Give it away.
My product is a day planner
for loan officers and real estate agents.
- Day planner.
- $25 for it.
They buy a subscription,
annual subscription.
We'll do an electronic version,
it's in the works right now.
- That's cool.
- 'Bout 2,000 users.
Should I just be givin' it
away instead of sellin'?
- Probably.
Because if you give it
away and you make it up
on the margin on the backend,
Freemium's always a better model.
Less friction.
- What is it?
- Lemme phrase, that's not fair.
Freemium is not always a better,
it's always fun to try the alternative
if you feel you've capped out.
I'm glad I just corrected myself.
I love Freemium, I think it's very smart.
You give something a piece of value.
You've got them into a
recurring revenue system.
They think they feel the
thing they got for free
pays for even the thing.
It's a good business idea,
but it's not the only one.
The other argument would
be to charge them more.
I'm always fascinated.
Everything between a number
and $99 interests me.
I'm fascinated by anything.
I think there's two
thresholds, 20 and 100.
I'm very fascinated about this
consumer behavior that I believe.
I believe if you're under 20,
like 20's the first hurdle.
It's 25?
- It's 35 by the individual.
99 if you do a subscription.
- Yeah, to me that's where it gets fun.
I love that place.
There were some woman's
that came to (mumbles),
I told her to take her $63 product to 99
and she's made a fortune.
'Cause there's just no difference.
I think we're very basic, 20, 100.
- [Man] We've got no advertising.
When we advertise, then try
the different price points
and see what sells.
- You could.
- Then give it away to people.
- I think one of the things...
One more time, this is a planner,
which is a utility for
them to be more efficient.
- [Man] It comes out every
quarter, gets shipped to 'em.
It's helpin' them track their time,
track their activities and their results
so they can determine what activity.
- I have to assume it SKUs older
because of the format of what it is.
- [Man] It's not, it's really interesting.
But you have younger people who are like
it's not on my phone, I can't use it.
- That's gonna continue to grow.
- [Man] Actually get that app piece out,
I think actually more people
will buy this to help support the app.
- I think that might be right.
- [Man] Right thing
somewhere during the day.
- Then what else?
They're paying you what?
- [man] Most people are
buyin' the subscription.
- What is the subscription
givin' them for $99?
- [Man] Gives them every
quarter it ships out.
- The end.
- At the end of the quarter,
it just shows up.
- There's no other products or services?
- [Man] No.
I mean right now we have a
free six to eight quickstart
where it downloads content to help 'em
figure out how to use it.
- Have you thought about adding
the level of once a quarter?
She had a group, his
business is built like this.
Have you thought about
doing once a quarter
or one hour virtual seminar
with everybody who's bought it?
- [Man] Got some stuff like that.
We've got a small, not
taken-off yet Facebook group.
- What are you doing in there
for it to take action?
- Not enough.
That's the challenge.
We're tryin' to figure
out what's gonna go.
We're gonna do two
webinars, one next week,
one the week after.
- I'll tell you one thing
that always works and it's
what I'm doin' with you.
If you've got expertise,
which is what scares
a lot of people from doin'
what I'm about to say.
But when you have expertise,
Q&A is the greatest.
It's the greatest.
This is the best format ever.
You're asking me what you wanna know.
What could possibly be better?
Because when I wanna talk,
you getting that for free
if you wanna watch it
or listen to it anyway.
Making it more of a community,
it's very obvious why her
business is doing well.
She's actually manifested a 5,000,
she's created a 5,000 person community.
They give a fuck.
- [Man] Facebook Live in the community.
- You could do Facebook Live,
you could do Skype.
There's a million things you could do.
You could try a lot of different things.
I'm less worried about the technology.
That's so advanced now.
The reason I'm hesitating
and just saying Facebook Live
is it may make sense for
you to do something else
that collects first-party data.
You may wanna invest a couple,
so people to call in have
to give you more data
when you're not at the mercy of Facebook.
There's a million ways
to think about this.
But what I think is clear
is you haven't layered
the high-touch stickiness
to the business yet,
which I think will create more
word of mouth and may evolve.
Here's why I like doin' stuff like this.
It may lead to somethin' I wanna do.
We don't get into the trenches enough.
I promise you this is
what always makes me laugh
about things like this.
I would've made New
York Times list anyway.
The value change on 350
books, eight times eight
is not gonna be a good
ROI for me in two hours.
Ever.
I always laugh when people
will say something about this
or anything else I do and they're like...
It's so funny how
not-thoughtful people are.
To me, the reason I do this
is I wanna force myself
through short-term little fun (mumbles)
to get into the trenches.
This is the trenches and
people don't like the trenches.
Trenches are hard.
- [Man] It's where all the magic happens.
- 100%, but we're all tryin'
to figure out scalability.
It's much more fun as a
solopreneur or a small business
including mine to think
about the scalable aspect
versus the digging deep,
especially when you been through it.
The youngsters here are on their journey.
You and I look at 'em and be like
you should be putting in the fuckin' work.
But we've been putting in
the work for 20, 30 years,
it's like fuck we have to put in the work?
Yup, you sure do.
They need to put in the work
'cause they need to establish
putting in the work.
We need to put in the work
because we can get caught
into our lazy habits
and the next guy or girl's right behind us
ready to put us outta business.
This is capitalism.
It's why I hate capitalism in
America in its current form,
which is you work your ass
off, you kill somebody.
It's a dog-eat-dog world,
then you become rich
and you use your money
to not allow it to change
so you can hold onto your money.
We're in fake capitalism in America now.
Old dudes are tryin' to change the rules
so they can keep the money
'cause they don't want the young lionesses
to take their shit.
- I want the young people
to take the product.
- By the way, it's the
internet that's gonna solve it.
- Well but (mumbles),
the average age is in their 50s.
(mumbles) that's it.
- Real estate is a great business.
As long as we live on this earth,
it will have value but where?
To me the recommendation
I give all my friends
like buy Manhattan, it's
Manhattan and be okay.
Never invest something you
can't afford to lose completely
because then you won't
have to invest, pull out.
You won't get caught in the margins.
Everything I have in Wall Street,
in which I don't trust
those fuckers down there
with anything, is completely predicated on
I will never look at it for
the rest of my entire life.
Doesn't exist.
That is why it's good to
build a personal brand
'cause it's yours in any market,
but it has to be built on truth and merit.
What I'm worried about is
everybody's getting ahead.
Conferences, Gary.
I don't have any money, I'm in debt.
I'm like lemme take you on.
You're at $7,000 in credit card debt?
Yes, what do I do?
I'm like the first thing you do
is fuckin' sell the $8,000
suit you're wearing.
Yeah but I was told I
have to look the part.
Just fuckin'.
- [Man] That's the other thing
that scares me too is because
we've been as a company
people know us as a company.
They don't know me personally
'cause we have such a big team now.
- Slowly.
Instead of fuckin' razz
pizzazz on fuckin' Instagram,
write a thoughtful six years
into my journey piece on LinkedIn.
Write a fuckin' post right
now on LinkedIn tonight
called six years in or make it clever.
This is where I'm creative.
365, 2,000 days into my journey.
A manifesto.
When you're writing and
you realize wait a minute,
I'm just writing about
nine things I've learned.
Cool, nine things I've learned
in my first 2,000 days in business.
Post.
Link in your email bio,
underneath all your
information CEO, Co-Founder.
Slowly but surely.
It's tortoise versus the hare, brother.
It's fuckin' as simple as that is.
What's so confusing is I have
the energy of a super hare,
but the actions of a tortoise.
- [Man] I appreciate the feedback.
- No I was gonna say that
so much of the advice given
is finish line driven.
(mumbles) like yours is
actually something out there,
whether it's recognition,
whether it's what you have.
But you said that early on
and if you realize the win,
the finish line is the journey.
- It's over.
Then it being flexible enough
to allow yourself to adjust.
Your life changes when you have a child.
He's a different man
at 22 than he is at 28.
You can't beat yourself
up for changing your mind,
you just have to be
thoughtful and self-aware
of why you're changing your mind.
- Sure.
- Maybe the person you fall
in love with is materialistic
and you're just in love with him or her.
You just are.
You fuckin' love 'em.
You wanna marry them and they love shit.
All of a sudden you're buyin'
shit you never bought before.
There's nothing
necessarily wrong with that
as long as you're grounded
into what's happening.
Like you're super proud of yourself
on never spending money on anything
and you kept it basic,
but then you fall in love.
He or she wants fuckin' a
fancy belt with a logo on it.
There's absolutely nothing wrong with that
because I have my own versions.
Maybe I don't wanna wear
fashion brands or watches,
but I like buying custom Jets jerseys
of random bench players.
That's a waste of $150 for a custom jersey
of a guy who might be on
the team in two months.
But when I go to a Jets game,
people are like you have
a blank blank jersey?
That's me peacocking I'm the best fan.
It's okay, but what's not okay
and what I'm tryin' to fix,
is you're doing it to
hide your insecurities
that you haven't made it yet.
That's not okay 'cause you'll lose.
You will lose.
If you want a BMW on money you don't have
because you wanna look
good amongst your peer set
that you've made it and
you haven't, you will lose.
You will lose.
Especially during this (mumbles) right now
where the market is good.
If you're not winning right
now, you really fuckin' suck.
(everyone laughing)
It's the truth 'cause
this is not fuckin' 2001.
This is not 2008.
You know how many less people
buy water filtration systems
when the fuckin' market collapses?
Less people.
You know how many less people
buy fuckin' cases of
$4,000 wine like today
happening at (mumbles)
when the market collapses?
Less people.
You know how many less
people buy fuckin' homes?
A lot less people.
Real life.
What's so fun for me is this is 100%.
I will not live the rest of my life
in a bullish market in growth.
Recalling like I can't
wait to air this content
the day the whole fuckin' world melts.
It's gonna be like I told you so
and I hope you did somethin' about it
because now it gets really weird.
- [Man] I heard you make that comment
about student loan debt.
- I'm gonna be so right about that.
I'm gonna be so historically
right about that.
They're lending money
to kids in huge debt.
There's nothin' else to say.
The banks are doing it again.
This time it's not bullshit mortgage,
things you guys understand better.
I still don't fully, I
understand packaging up more shit
and not having a true system.
You guys probably in the
younger self, you guys know.
You have friends or acquaintances
who are 180,000 in debt on 9% interest
are making 47,000 a year and
are buying expensive shit
or have a new apartment.
- That's true.
- It's goin' to be so bad.
- [Man] Gary, two or three things
you might tell literally a minute of,
you may tell new or newer realtors.
- I think the real estate
industry, I kbow a lot about it.
My sister just became one, too.
- I saw that.
- We threw a conference.
I know it really well and have spoken at.
Thank you.
First of all, I think it
trades too much on its history.
I think the Old Guard,
much like marketing,
is respected too much.
I think that's a
fundamental starting point.
It's so funny.
I love how I think about the world
'cause it's in opposite direct.
I just basically have talked
about old school tactics
and my opening line is don't
fuckin' respect the old school.
You said new, right?
- Yeah.
- They're getting advice
from old school dogs
who are saying shit that
isn't relevant anymore.
I'm blown away by the enormity of advice.
I mean I don't know, just
a lot of tried and true
that isn't tried and true.
The only reason they're
getting away with it
is that they've built up enough
of a base and a reputation.
They're trading off their
brand and their reputation,
not off of the new tactics.
But if you're new and you're 24
and nobody knows who the fuck you are,
you're not trading on your reputation.
- Okay.
- That's number one.
I think social media aka Facebook
and Instagram especially,
but I do think LinkedIn
even in a real estate world
is really tricky interesting.
Google, YouTube, Pre-Roll for sure.
If you are not a practitioner
of modern day marketing,
you are irrelevant.
I think you're in the
business of being good
at Facebook and Instagram
and Linkedin and YouTube.
(mumbles) real estate agent.
When you make that decision,
I think that's true
for all of you.
If you actually think
you're a marketing company
for your company first,
whether you then go and
hire somebody to do it
because you've become educated
and somebody can't rip you off,
or you actually fall in love
with it and do it in parallel.
Or what I'm starting to see from people
is that I taught them to do it.
They got good at it and
you know what happens.
You're living it already.
Them people wanna pay
you to do it for them.
All of a sudden you build
a $15 million agency
for plumbers to market their business.
That makes real life and
that's where people struggle.
Do I stay the course of my business?
Do I become the personality
and make money that way?
Or do I start a service business or that?
I'm sure this has run through
everybody's listening around.
I chose to do it a very weird way.
I chose to do it.
I built my library based on the machine
that is VaynerMedia but I'm not trying
to build VaynerMedia,
I'm trying to build
VaynerMedia to then go back
and build businesses on the back of it.
- [Man] Which is genius.
- Right?
You see where I'm goin'?
I did it then I built a
service business for it
with the idea then to make it so X scale
that I could do it
bigger, better than ever.
That I could buy Schweppes for 200 million
and the make everybody in America
drink ginger ale because I'm gonna get
little Yadi and Instagram
models drinking Schweppes.
Schweppes will have the best voice app.
There'll be pre-rolled Schweppes pads
for direct to consumer because
you once searched ginger ale
on Google and now you're
watching a fishing video.
- [Man] And it'll come
out of the water system.
(group laughing)
- [Man] The business model,
if you don't like it,
can you elaborate on that?
- Sure.
- [Man] Both yours and what
your doing for companies now.
- Meaning?
One more time, I wanna make
sure I understood the question.
Vayner your talking about?
- Vayner, yes.
- Vayner is a client service business.
We get paid.
We sell people.
It's a really bad business.
It's a bad business even
when I think you run it well.
We don't run it well
'cause it's not its intent.
We'll probably eventually be doing
500 million at 15% net profit.
That's a good business.
I don't wanna pee on it, right?
But it's a difficult business.
You're at the mercy of people.
Just people.
I'm in the HR business 24/7.
Which is fine, I like that.
To me, I come up with
the products and service.
Some of the services are obvious, right?
Paid media.
We'll spend your media, you'll
pay us a commission on that.
But where do you put your focus?
We did it on Facebook seven years ago.
So now we're a leader.
If I sold things, if I
was willing to do Google,
and I was willing to do Direct Mail,
I would have been bigger.
'Cause that's what people
were paying for at the time.
So my model is bet on
something you believe in.
Build towards that goal,
out far enough that you become the leader.
But not too far that
you go out of business
before you get there.
Then my plan is to take
the best talent here
and deploy it against other
things that I buy or start.
So thinking about starting
a men's shampoo brand.
'Cause I actually don't think there's any
shampoo brand that speaks to us, for real.
Like what, Dove Men's?
I will take four pieces
of talent from here
that'll no longer work on client business
and they'll be the this,
that, the art, the creative.
The media, the strategy and so
I'm building an infrastructure.
But you have to reverse engineer yourself.
You guys know me a little bit better.
You got a better sense
of me even right now.
This would break if I wasn't a good guy
'cause this is completely held up by HR.
This is being held up on the fact
that Babin doesn't wanna leave.
So when Babin goes and starts working
for the men's media company
that I'm launching this summer,
which is probably true other
than I love him so much
that I'll have to keep him once in a while
for like, blogging for me.
The thing that's making
him not leave is me.
That was his game plan.
What was it again, Babin man?
- [Babin] Work for you for a year
and then leverage your name.
(Gary laughing)
- And how long are we in now?
- [Babin] Over two years.
- I know that you'll tell the truth.
What are you thinkin' now?
- [Babin] I'll be here for a long time.
- (chuckles) You know?
And whether that's three years
or nine or seven or life,
he'll evolve, like back to...
I'm always of the mindset, he'll fall...
What if he falls in love
with somebody that comes
to one of these events who...
She lives in India and that's it.
He had to move to India.
That's cool.
That's life.
I'm always open for everything.
I know what my plans are.
I built the framework.
My preference is it works
on everybody forever.
It's okay if it doesn't.
This is a very unique company
that's very difficult to
replicate because I'm unique.
But you're all unique in your way
and you need to figure that out.
I'm very big on deploying
against your strengths.
Make content that fits you.
I was in a premium wine business
and was ridiculous with my content.
I'm selling $150 bottles of wine
referencing Hillbilly Jim taking a crap.
- [Man] Since I'm jumping
from one to another,
how do I know that this is the thing
I wanna do for the rest of my life?
- I think you've probably
heard this about love to?
And I mean this, I think you just know.
I really do.
When you really know in business,
it's gonna be two things.
Very early significant
success and you're loving it.
For not the money.
That's why all the other
stuff matters so much.
If you're not trying to catch up to Rick;
If you're not trying to impress Sally,
then the way you're gonna know
is you love it for loving it,
not for the money it's giving it to you.
So many of my internet contemporaries,
'cause I can't call them friends
'cause I can't be friends
with somebody like this,
loves stuff because of the money.
They loved affiliate
marketing 'cause of the money.
They love network marketing
and LML because of the money.
If you're the kind of
person that's okay with
ripping people off for your own self gain
because you need the money
and you're that insecure,
I'm not gonna...
Who the fuck am I?
I'm not gonna judge you,
it's just not my cup of tea.
It's not who I am or what I'm about
or who I wanna associate with.
I don't care how fast your car is
or how hot your chicks are.
Just not interested.
- It's gonna be fun to watch you.
- [Man] If I don't figure out
what I wanna do until I graduate,
my dad's probably gonna pull my ears
and put him in his business.
- That makes sense.
The good news is you don't have to go.
You think you have to go
because you're letting
them have a leverage point.
That leverage is normally money not love.
Everybody comes up with excuses, kids too.
You love to say you don't
wanna let your dad down.
What you mean is your not sure how
you're gonna maintain a decent lifestyle.
It's peoples inability
or want to pay the price
for the big stuff.
Which is crazy to me in college because
that's when you should find your homies.
The number one piece of advice
I have if you're a winner
is find three other winners.
Look at each other and say
22 to 27, we're together.
Let's fucking go.
Now with the internet,
where people are building businesses,
you don't need New York or
San Francisco or San Diego.
Go on to Mississippi.
Cost of living is low.
Go live right next to
a fuckin' White Castle
that you can walk to.
(group giggling)
I'm being serious by the way.
As long as you have an
internet connection, let's go.
I'm giving you my dream.
I wish I knew that.
I wanted to pay back my parents
for what they did for me.
It wasn't a drag.
I signed up for going there for a while,
building something for them.
I like not owing anybody anything.
I love the feeling that
my parents and I are even
which is a rare thing for a kid to say,
especially with the
amazingness that my parents are
and what they did for me.
We're probably still not even
'cause they fuckin' really did it for me.
But I like it.
I'm a helluva lot closer than most people
'cause I really did something for them.
For real.
So that's cool so I like that.
But if I didn't have that
gear or that well parented...
Fuck me man, nothing's
more interesting right now
than to go to Mississippi
with my five college
friends and literally,
there's nothing like building something.
It was much more fun
before it was six figures.
Those first few, right?
- [Brooke] Yes.
- There's nothing like
building something, right?
- It's true.
- Of course.
This is all a burden now.
It's so fun when you don't
know what the fuck you're doing
and you're just trying to figure it out
and your just fucking ghetto to the max.
That's what I want.
Listen, I like Rocky when
he's drinking the egg...
I like that.
That's why I want people
to love the process
and it gets a lot harder
when you have a husband
or wife, kids, stuff.
The big mistake is not
the making of the money,
it's the spending of the money.
- When we think about it though,
that's the thing though.
When we're pushing back
on college, the thing is
that so many of them I think know
that the big companies
want you to have a degree.
- Correct.
- But I don't think that matters, right?
- Doesn't matter here any more.
We're hiring a ton of people without it.
- So instead of them going and
spending 30, 50,000 dollars--
- Dude, it makes no sense.
- Right, it's ridiculous.
- It's so broken.
It's trading on two things.
Historical truth, which, yes,
if you wanted to get a job
in 1989 in America, that was good.
It was a really good idea.
And insecurity of parents
to trade on the brand
that their kids go to
so they can look good
to their other friends.
- [Man] I think the
companies can actually be
the new universities.
- They will be.
It's over and you have to
understand why it's over.
The internet's the middle.
If you're not native to it...
It doesn't mean that brokers,
real estate agents, get replaced.
What it means is brokerages get replaced.
People don't get it, it's fucked.
The end person is hard to replace.
A robot's not going to
show her the house so fast.
But everything else.
Like Vayner brokerage,
I've thought about it a ton
through the last three years.
I'm like, man.
One of the reasons Berkshire's
is a lot of fun for me
is I get to learn it as well.
The big thesis of Vayner is to learn.
I've so many things I'm gonna do
so I'm not gonna go into the businesses
of any of my clients.
The first thing I'm gonna do
is something completely different
than anybody we ever had
and we're getting big
and sort of eliminate things.
So I've actually said no
to some things recently
'cause I'm like, well,
fuck, I may wanna do
a bottled water, you know?
Anyway, none the less.
But fuck man, I already know
it didn't take that many
meetings that I knew it
before I even grabbed them.
I kinda said yes 'cause of Gino too.
It's really funny.
We both did the same fucking thing.
Vayner, you know this too.
My brokerage would destroy
everybody else's brokerage
'cause everything's a commodity other than
building up the agent and I know how to
build up the agent a hell of lot better
than giving you a book of leads
and (mumbles) and giving
you a fucking business card.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That's where the leverage is.
So super interesting.
That's the whole leverage of everything.
Calms is the leverage.
Communication, marketing.
Like that's the leverage for anything.
As long as your products
not a piece of shit,
the variables are
happening in the marketing
and the positioning and the brand.
You got kids that are going into math,
but math is not how you sell Nike.
So you can be awesome
at Google and Facebook
but you have to build brand too.
And then you have the big companies
that don't care about the new math.
So that's what a delta is.
You gotta respect the art and
the science of the new world.
- [Man] Another thing to figure
out is what's gonna replace
at that college level
their ability to interact.
Face to face, like a---
- Life.
- [Man] The kid, yeah.
The hyperbolean bullshit
of I'm gonna send my kid
to a campus and that's where he or she
is gonna become a man or
woman and get life skills,
it's horseshit.
It's a fake environment.
Life, life is gonna make them a man.
And it's crazy.
Why don't they get paid for having a year
to do something and send them...
You'll get a helluva
lot more life and fun.
Let's put them all on a
fucking cruise for two weeks.
It's so broken.
It's so broken, it's gonna come down.
Look, what we're really bad
at is respecting history.
In 1951, no one gave a fuck about college.
Then they did but it wasn't
the American dream or the must.
You got skills.
You were taught skills in high school.
You were taught skills and
you went and got a job.
And then through a lot
of smart positioning
and marketing and
behavior and big business,
college was able to win.
At the default for us, you had to at least
go to a community college.
Guess what, you still got debt there too
if you didn't have the money to pay.
Your oldest is 16?
- Yeah.
- You're in a funny spot right now, right?
- Mm mmm.
- Because probably what
you thought 10 years ago
has been affected by...
If you were sitting here,
you're affected by the truth.
Meaning, I don't know where
you sit on college or not,
but I promise you, it hasn't gained
momentum from 10 years ago.
It can only be neutral.
If you loved it, if you were
an academic and if you loved...
If you were a college professor,
and over the last 10 years, there's no way
you believe in it more.
You may believe in the
same because you haven't
been allowed to hear what's happening.
But if you're an average parent right now
with the 16 year old, you probably
believe in college less
than you did 10 years ago.
But you're still of the parenting
generation that's caught.
- [Man] Guilt.
- I went to school for six
years, never graduated.
- Right.
- But I learned there how to manipulate.
- Understood, you learned systems.
- My wife, on the other
hand, she graduated
in early child education and so she is...
- A product of that.
- I'm gonna be completely
honest at this point.
- Yes.
- They need to go to college and I'm like,
they don't need college at all.
- Right.
Are you gonna pay for college?
Who's the oldest, boy or girl?
- He's a boy.
- You gonna pay for it?
- I don't how I'm gonna tell him no.
- Correct, you just know that
you're a good enough guy...
What you just answered is
I'm not gonna force him
and not pay.
- That's right.
- That's my biggest problem.
The biggest problem in
the system right now
is parents are forcing their
kids to go and aren't paying.
The biggest problem with college
is parents are being pieces of shit.
They're forcing their kids to collect debt
to make themselves look good
because on August 16
when the kid goes away
and they go to dinner with their friends
whose kid also went away...
Ricky went to Princeton, I feel great.
Ricky's about to fuckin'
be $400,000 in debt
and Ricky luckily is going to Princeton
so probably he can get
a job at Bayern McKenzie
or Goldman Sachs.
Probably after seven
years, he'll get there.
But that's the 1%.
The kid that's going to Penn State
that's getting fuckin' $189,000 in debt,
whose parents feel good
'cause they only went to
community college but Penn
State seems like a level up
but they're not paying,
they're on the money.
They're making you go, that's the norm.
That kid isn't graduating Penn
State in 2022 with anything.
- [Brooke] Even my parents,
they've come around to the idea
that it's not as valuable.
- [Man] No, it's not.
- And it was.
I'm not mad at people.
It was a good idea in '78.
It was a good idea.
There was jobs lined up for you.
That became the new norm.
In the same way skills are
now gonna become the new norm.
I don't know where Babin
went to fuckin' college.
I looked at the video.
I don't know if he went to college.
He sure didn't.
(group laughing)
- [Man] He may have been in prison.
- Probably.
(muffled crosstalk)
- [Man] Question, how does one
reach their full potential?
Everyday when I've decided,
okay, I'm gonna call
10 businesses one day but I don't wanna
bullshit myself with some
of the other excuses.
Because I know in the back of my head,
oh, that's got a business, I'm good.
So how do I stop bullshitting
myself with excuses
when I should...
- Look, the fact that
you could even articulate
that question, has you
so much further along.
Anybody that has the ability to say,
"dad has a business, I'm good,"
you've been listening.
So you're already on your way.
Honestly, I don't even
wanna answer a question
'cause I'm already happy for you.
You're on your way.
One thing I would say is
full potential or 10 calls.
These are arbitrary things.
What's full potential?
I can't define that.
These are things we're
imposing on ourselves.
Why is 10 calls the magic number
to feel good about yourself?
Why couldn't it be three or 700?
Got it?
So know what's real and what's not real.
You said a very important real thing
which is your concerned that the cushion
is siphoning out your ambition.
That's up to you, here's
what I can tell you.
One man lives life where regret
is the only things that's scary.
Everyone's wired differently.
To me, the thought of
somebody saying that...
One of the reasons I own nothing of...
I've been talking a lot more about
not owning anything of my library
because I didn't want people...
As I've gotten more popular
and I'm putting pressure on the system,
people are pushing back at
me who are trying to get
your money and saying well
he was handed everything.
I was like, fuck, I
always protected my dad
'cause I always thought
it was a little weird
that I never owned anything.
But now I'm getting into
even more of an honest place
to be very frank.
My most honest place,
Babin has never heard this.
First time I've ever saying it out loud.
I think I secretly made sure
I didn't know any of it.
He wasn't giving and I wasn't asking.
It took two to tango.
I didn't put pressure on my dad to give me
anything of the business
because I think for me,
subconsciously and maybe consciously
after I got to 28 or 29,
but definitely not at 23 or 24.
But definitely at 28, 29, 30,
I realized I was on my way to doing things
and I didn't anybody to have an excuse.
I didn't want anybody to say
I was successful because of that.
So you just need to try
to get to know yourself.
So you may say I'm going into the business
and I'm gonna make it 500 times bigger.
You may say that to yourself.
Then you may say that will prove
that I'm good or what have you.
Then I would say to you, people are still
gonna come up with excuses.
So you just gotta know yourself.
- So it's interesting.
You're not letting good
get in the way of great.
You don't wanna be
distracted by comfortable,
safe and comfortable.
- What kind of business is it?
- [Man] It's kind of like Time Warner.
We supply internet and cable
to seven states in India.
- Is it your dad's business
or is he the executive of it?
- [Man] He's one of the owners.
Him and his friend
dropped out of high school
in sophomore year and then they started
and went on and got more people.
- That's a big business.
- [Man] It kind of is.
- Yeah.
You're dealing with what I'm
worried about for my kids,
which is do you wanna climb the mountain
or do you wanna run
away from the mountain?
And both are right.
I'm not even gonna use run away
from the mountain ever again.
This is me and my process.
Running away seems like a negative.
It's appropriate.
If I was my own son,
I would fuckin' not do
anything close to I was...
I would try to become the
biggest artist in the world.
Because it would have been like, fuck.
It's daunting 'cause I want my own path.
That's who I am.
With the same chemicals that I have,
I would have wanted my own path.
So look man, if it's that real,
sounds like it's super real.
You need to try to figure
out what makes you tick
and it's very cliched for
kids to have very opposite
reactions to very
significant parent success.
You either wanna go crazy
and build a fuckin' empire
or you wanna go save the
world or give it all back.
Not play the same score.
- [Man] I think that
is what the problem is.
I have zero self confidence right now.
- I think you have a lot, bro.
I think the fact that you're
even using the terminology...
I think that you are early in the process.
But I think that you even know what
self-awareness is is
a good starting point.
Lack of self-awareness is
not even acknowledging its existence.
You don't know yourself yet,
but that makes sense.
Most of us didn't.
- [Man] So it's okay to not know
what I'm going to do with my degree
after a year of undergraduate?
- 100% brother, it's preferable.
- [Man] Can you like get hired by anyone?
- Yeah.
- 'Til I figure out
what's going on.
- 100%.
My preference would be that
you get hired somewhere
where it still gives you free time to get
to know yourself too.
You also have to understand
if you're doing it
for yourself or if
you're doing it for them.
If you're getting hired because you think
that's what your parents want,
you need to get to that place first.
As long as your willing to live
without them supporting you financially,
well then you're off to the races.
That's the leverage.
- [Man] For me, my end
point is my family saying,
"Yeah, we're proud of you."
- I get it, it's very cultural
for India and Russia and Asia.
If you're brown, Asian
or Eastern European,
we're all slight little
versions of the same shit.
So I've always been very empathetic to it.
Let me give you some really good advice.
Making your parents proud on
their terms in the short term,
often leads to a very bad
relationship in the long term
and those years hurt.
So a little pain in the beginning
is a lot better than a
ton of pain at the end.
It's easy to say when
you're not in it, like I am.
But it's the truth.
- [Man] It's especially
hard when me and my dad...
He's the one supporting me and everything.
I mean financially, the lot,
like typical---
- Old school, yeah I get it.
You're communicating through your mom.
- [Man] Exactly right.
(group laughing)
- I get it.
- How do you know?
- I know because...
The reason I'm good at this stuff
is because there's only
18 to 44 things in life.
Life's basic.
I just know.
I've also lived it.
That's exactly what
happened with me and my dad.
Luckily, I worked directly
for him and with him
and over time we got there.
But would have been my life.
That is my brother's life.
That is my sister's life.
- [Man] So are you still close to him?
- I'm very close to him,
but what I did and what
I would recommend to you
is to have the leverage.
- [Man] So I actually go work for him?
- My answer to leverage is
not to be held accountable
to his finances.
College is one thing.
He wanted that.
But the day you end
is the day you don't take another dollar.
It's 100% right, self-reliance.
You can't allow it;
otherwise the relationship is skewed.
Let me promise you one thing.
That is going to garner more respect
than anything you'll ever do,
especially if your dad
wants you to take it.
Because the other thing
with old school dads
is they want you to take it
because they like using it as leverage.
As long as you're taking it,
then he can make you do what he wants.
- [Man] He's not the kind
who's like do this, do that.
- Good.
You're off to a better
place than most then.
Then you need to be in a place
where you don't take the money.
You get in that place, you'll win.
That's the right advice and
that's why kids piss me off.
I do a lot of content for
the kids and they love me.
But then when I get one on one,
I'm like, you're a piece of shit.
You want the money, but don't
wanna listen to your parents.
They're paying for the right
to tell you what to do.
Get off the payroll.
You're such a big shot?
You can't have both.
You can't have the fuckin' Mercedes
and the fuckin' gym membership
that your parents are paying for;
but then do it exactly how you want,
spitting in their face
against what they want.
Right?
So either you're your
own person or you're not.
It's binary.
I love when people are like,
it's so fun for me,
it's just sitting here.
I don't even wanna leave.
All these meetings and emails and DMs
and conversations I have.
Yo, I'm independent.
Well, they do pay for the gym.
And I do have an Amazon stipend
and Uber is on my dad's credit card.
I'm like, you're on the payroll.
(group laughing)
You're on the fucking payroll.
Get off the payroll and do
whatever the fuck you want.
Stay on the payroll and do
whatever the fuck they want.
- So we're meeting here
every week now?
- Yeah, this is it.
This is it.
(soft rhythmic music)